donde nos quedamos teníamos este campo
vectorial en dos dimensiones y lo hemos
pintado aquí como un campo amarillo
verdad simplemente lo pusimos en un
espacio de tres dimensiones y esto era
un poco raro porque pusimos el plano xy
verdad y dijimos que pretendíamos que
estuviera en tres dimensiones y esto
servía para describir la rotación
alrededor de cada punto donde ya ya
estamos familiarizados con el rotacional
en dos dimensiones verdad pero ahora
queremos un campo vectorial en tres
dimensiones porque queremos asignarle
vectores tridimensionales que nos
indiquen la rotación así que vamos a
tratar de extender todo esto a un campo
vectorial en tres dimensiones arbitrario
así que déjenme borrar todo esto verdad
vamos a borrar todas las las cuentas de
del vídeo pasado y ahora vamos a tratar
de empezar a pensar en cómo podríamos es
extender el campo vectorial que teníamos
anteriormente verdad que era
bidimensional esencialmente ahora a tres
dimensiones y una idea que podríamos
considerar es copiar este campo en
distintas rebanadas y podrían verse más
o menos así donde hemos dibujado varias
rebanadas
es un poco separadas verdad pero
técnicamente el original se ve
exactamente igual en cada rebanada
verdad así que por supuesto tenemos
muchos más vectores pero esencialmente
en cada rebanada tenemos el mismo campo
vectorial si lo vemos desde arriba
quizás se ve mucho más claro verdad que
es un montón de copias del mismo campo
verdad que estamos digamos si ponemos el
plano xy verdad entonces tenemos en las
rebanadas el mismo campo vectorial e
incluso digamos no sé tendremos cinco o
siete rebanadas que tenemos aquí pero
pensamos que tenemos una infinidad de
estas verdad una infinidad de estas
copias del campo vectorial entonces en
fórmulas como cómo podemos escribir esto
vamos a borrar esto porque ahora va a
depender de tres variables vamos a poner
una variable zeta también verdad y
entonces vamos a considerar vectores en
tres dimensiones en lugar de sólo dos
componentes verdad así que nuestra
componente zeta
en la salida verdad no depende de z pero
tiene que ser cero y el hecho de que
tengamos acepta en la entrada pero en la
salida no depende
z corresponde al hecho de que las
rebanadas son las mismas al movernos en
la dirección z verdad simplemente son
copias las zonas de las otras y el hecho
de que tengamos una tercera componente
en la salida y que sea 0 corresponder al
hecho de que en realidad se ve muy plano
ya sabes en realidad no hay no hay
vector que apunte en la dirección se
está simplemente en las direcciones de
xy de y así que el campo vectorial en
tres dimensiones más o menos se ve así
verdad esto parece en realidad que no es
tridimensional pero en realidad es un
muy buen ejemplo verdad porque si ahora
empezamos a pensar en la representación
del fluido en tres dimensiones verdad
podríamos por ejemplo recordar el
ejemplo que teníamos en dos dimensiones
en donde teníamos las moléculas de agua
y se movían de esta forma es muy fácil
entender la rotación o en sentido
horario o antihorario verdad pero cuando
tenemos el caso en tres dimensiones se
vuelve algo muy caótico porque esto que
teníamos plano verdad quizás si lo vemos
desde arriba
a lo mejor nos da una idea de la de la
rotación en el sentido horario o
antihorario verdad así que por ejemplo
si dibujamos esta columna podría
pensar que en esta columna tendríamos
como una especie de tornado del fluido
verdad todo está rotando
digamos siguiendo esa dirección y si
asignamos un vector a cada punto en el
espacio que describa este tipo de
rotación ocurre que cada uno de estos
puntos verdad sí sí estamos dentro de
esta columna entonces estaríamos girando
en este tornado en el sentido
antihorario por supuesto que si lo vemos
desde abajo se vería en dirección
contraria por eso necesitamos usar
vectores y utilizar la regla de la mano
derecha donde giramos nuestros dedos
siguiendo la dirección de la rotación
verdad y al levantar el pulgar vemos la
dirección z en este caso se apuntan
hacia arriba verdad en la dirección
positiva pero si mostramos todas estas
flechas se ve un desorden así que vamos
a borrar las flechas amarillas por un
momento verdad y solo nos vamos a
enfocar en el nuevo campo vectorial que
hemos encontrado y dentro de la columna
tenemos que la rotación del tornado como
lo estábamos describiendo todos estos
vectores apuntan en la dirección z
verdad pero si lo hubiéramos digamos en
otro lado digamos en esta región
entonces apuntan en la dirección
negativa
así que si levantamos el pulgar en la
dirección de todos estos vectores en la
dirección z negativa esto nos dice que
el fluido rotará en el sentido de las
manecillas del reloj así que podríamos
pensar que esto es como aire que está
atravesando una habitación en tres
dimensiones entonces vamos a tratar de
ver qué es lo que nos dice el rotacional
tenemos una fórmula del último vídeo que
espero no se haya arruinado mucho verdad
y la forma en cómo describimos esto fue
con un campo vectorial en dos
dimensiones pero ahora estamos
considerando una tercera variable así
que es un campo vectorial bien
construido la salida nos dice en cada
punto del espacio cuál es la rotación
que corresponde a cada punto verdad y en
el próximo vídeo veremos la fórmula de
cómo calcular el rotacional para una
función arbitraria ahorita solo vamos a
tratar de obtener intuición visual y una
forma digamos de hacer esto es pensar en
varias copias del campo vectorial en dos
dimensiones pero este tipo de ejemplos
son muy artificiales porque la rotación
ocurre en estos tipos de patrones como
de tornados que en realidad no cambian
al movernos en la dirección
verdad pero más en general si
consideramos un campo vectorial más
complicado así que por ejemplo como este
que estoy por poner vamos a poner un
campo vectorial más complicado que
corremos todo esto si también vamos a
borrarlo consideremos ahora este campo
vectorial digamos que que estamos
mostrando aquí verdad aquí por ejemplo
es muy difícil de pensar cómo es que el
flujo asociado con este campo va a rotar
tenemos una noción un poco vaga más o
menos de cómo es que está fluyendo esto
por ejemplo en la esquina pero es muy
difícil de pensar todo es todos los
puntos al mismo tiempo y ciertamente si
si pensamos en la rotación es muy
difícil de fijarnos en un punto y decir
ah mira aquí se ve que el fluido está
haciendo una rotación general de alguna
forma verdad pero al menos tenemos una
idea muy vaga por ejemplo si pensamos en
esta pelota verdad en este punto
específico y aquí esta pelota pues ésta
está girando en el espacio verdad
podríamos imaginar que este nuevo campo
vectorial está induciendo cierta fuerza
en esta pelota para que esté flotando y
girando en el espacio así que si
pensamos en esto
a pelotas digamos de tenis verdad y las
sostenemos en ese lugar no sé quizás
usando algún truco de magia o qué sé yo
y dejamos que el viento empiece a
hacerlo rotar entonces podemos describir
este movimiento con alguna especie de
vector que en este caso será un vector
que apunta en la dirección esta
dirección verdad porque justamente si
doblamos nuestros dedos hacia la
dirección de la rotación
entonces obtenemos este vector verde
verdad y si no entiendes cómo se
describen las rotaciones en tres
dimensiones con un vector checa los
vídeos anteriores de este tema verdad
así que la idea aquí es que tenemos
cierto tipo de fluido quizás muy loco
que está inducido por un campo vectorial
y si en cada punto pensamos en la
rotación que induce este campo vectorial
en realidad estamos pensando en el
rotacional en tres dimensiones de este
campo eso es lo que trata de representar
y yo sé que es bastante confuso y que
quizás al inicio es muy difícil de
atrapar las ideas en tu mente pero no te
preocupes todos hemos pasado por eso en
realidad el concepto del rotacional en
tres dimensiones es quizás uno de los
más complicados en el cálculo de varias
variables
y yo creo que la clave para entender
esto es simplemente pensar de forma muy
paciente todo lo que lo que significa el
rotacional en dos dimensiones y tratar
de extenderlo a tres dimensiones
lentamente muy bien así que por ejemplo
podríamos pensar en los tornados de
rotación y ver si eso tiene sentido
tratar de entender cómo representar
estas rotaciones en tres dimensiones en
un punto gracias a un vector verdad y
tratar de entender
finalmente el rotacional en tres
dimensiones como si hiciéramos este tipo
de ejemplos en cada punto del espacio